so we've seen in the film that it can
definitely transform someone's body yeah
but how can it how can whooping
transform someone's mind and their whole
persona my god so many ways I'm actually
writing a book called insights from the
circle and it's all about all the
insights that that I came upon through
my journey with the hoop and there's
just so many parallels for life that for
me occurred naturally as I was hooping
it was kind of like those aha moments
you know like there's a sweet spot that
you find between being in action and
also being in surrender that I think is
that sweet spot in life that if we can
find that in life of being active in our
lives but also being kind of fluid and
surrendering to the circumstances that
happen to us you know our lives go a lot
better and that's how the hoop really
finds flow is you know too much action
and everything gets rigid and it's
wobbly and it's funky too much surrender
and it just slows down and falls so you
kind of are guided to find that sweet
spot and it really is psychological even
more so in some ways than physical and
finding that and the hoop makes it a lot
easier to find it in your life and it
just happened it's a natural process
it's not something that you have to
necessarily you know intentionally do
although it can be helpful if you're
conscious of it but I find that it's
something that is just like you know
there'll be a moment where you go oh wow
that little thing is just like this
other thing I do in my life and whew
these things are all going together you
know so it's just a natural thing I
think especially if you are a person
that likes to look for opportunities to
grow and transform which I am those
those things will come out even more in
the hoop yeah
you